freaky Party
Time see
that they're a
natural
good start now finish the
job it slices it di rip them to
Pieces head
reload
this
ugly finish the last ones off so I can
open the Traer P for
you you wanted in personal scum bag new
mag don't come
back perfect podt is open again let's
get you
restocked [__] glad you made it back
don't leave on
anything anyone still alive out
there we're doing great team keep
watching what I do all
right keep your bloody head in the
game
where are they
all or almost out of time make your
choices
yeah love a bit of the picture postcard
snow come on you know it's
classy know what almost impress still
alive I have to power down the Pod don't
ruin our lucky
streak time's up go kill some
Zeds solid performance so far but I'm
not loving the
quiet just like the L and the F
did need the
hands
the taking some
punishment your attention
a let's call that your warm up on that
door
cut like a ninja there it
is damn
it
going to break something you
bastard nearly cleared this batch out
nice work we can reopen the trailer
part
on
reloading I'll fight
you come see me the Pod safely open
nicely
done it's quiet and we're all
alive right keep your bloody head in the
game